con más de 32.000 personas siendo
tratadas en los hospitales a la fecha lo
que significa un incremento del 22 por
ciento con respecto a la semana pasada
el ministro de salud man hancock y el
jefe médico del gobierno el profesor
cris güity advirtieron que el reino
unido está pasando por lo peor de la
pandemia con la alta probabilidad de que
la situación se ponga aún más compleja
con el aumento disparado de casos y de
muertes por ello el gobierno le ha
insistido a la población en que deben
quedarse en la casa en que se debe
evitar cualquier contacto que no sea
esencial y entretanto el alcalde de
londres a beckham quien decretó hace
unos días el estado de emergencia en la
capital británica ha insistido en que el
gobierno debe endurecer aún más estas
medidas en medio de este tercer
confinamiento nacional en el que estamos
ha dicho que debe hacerse por ejemplo el
uso del tapabocas obligatorio porque en
este momento no lo es en lugares
públicos como las filas de los
supermercados y otros el gobierno
entretanto lanzó hoy su campaña
ambiciosa
acción que tiene nueva etapas nueve
etapas ya se inició con esta vacunación
ya se han vacunado dos millones de
personas un poco más pero se espera que
las vulnerables al menos 15 millones de
personas estén vacunadas para mitad de
febrero otras 21 millones de personas se
espera que estén vacunadas para la
primavera y el resto de la población
sobre los 18 años podría estar bajo nada
para el otoño para ello se han creado se
han puesto en funcionamiento 2700
puestos de vacunación entre ellos 7 mega
centros en londres y en las principales
ciudades del país